welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we have our friend
Mayim Bialik who she's on Big Bang
Theory I heard of that show she's also
been a guest on good mythical morning
she's also on GM and um she's gonna be
in buddy system she's that much of a
friend that was getting her and she is
nice to us she also wrote a book that
we're gonna talk about curling up how to
be strong smart and spectacular
neuroscientist actress grownup girl
Mayim Bialik PhD wrote this thing and
we're gonna have a special guest very
dear to my heart my daughter Lily is
gonna be he's gonna join the
conversation with my him yeah you know I
know that she's going to because we
already shot we already recorded we and
she's also she's sitting she's right
there we had a great we had a great
conversation
Lily will make you question if she's
actually related to link that's how well
spoken is Marcia you know what that's I
thank you yeah I'll take that backhanded
compliment before we get into that
conversation when this podcast goes up
it will be one day before the streamys
yes so tomorrow night if if on release
day for yes thing will be all dolled up
man yeah it gets to take home some
awards yes I mean and I think we kind of
made this clear but just and we probably
will have made it clear in other ways
before this podcast but you know we
believe in we think the streamys are a
great thing we believe in the concept of
an Internet award show and I don't even
necessarily first of all the vast
majority of the awards that will be
given tomorrow night are things that are
determined by like an actual you know
Academy a committee or whatever and
where what what Awards do we have for
we've got a button system every system
is comedy GMM show of the year and then
buddy system for Best Director as well
for John Fortenberry director of season
one a buddy system
so we'd love to take one of those home
but specifically show of the year and
personality of the year what a person I
don't know what it is which we're not
nominated for Person of the Year the way
they determine those now is by popular
vote and we honestly were just like
listen we made a big push for this last
year the year before I don't know and
everybody did all this work and it was
just like I always felt a little bit
dirty asking for votes you know because
you got to cut you have to constantly
bombard people but because because
people vote
yeah and they they can vote as MIT they
can bombard votes like a whole bunch in
a day every day leading to once a day
but I mean I'm sure people do multiple
accounts and people end up doing a lot
of work like it takes a lot of work to
do it and so anyway and we and we do
you're right we don't we haven't felt
great about asking always feel weird
about asking for votes for anything I
just want to win an award based on the
merit but I do understand the strategy
and so I don't know and and and listen I
part of the strategy is that when you
vote on Twitter or wherever you vote it
it churns a conversation about the
streamys which i believe in and so i so
by design there it's it's something that
they engage fans to talk about who
they're passionate about and also talk
about something that they may not be
obsession about which is the stream even
ordered all these implemented irrelevant
part of the more relevant conversation
when you get all these artificial the
entire strategy and I'm not faulting the
strategy it's one of the reasons that
we're talking about the stream news
right now now but as you know instead of
we ask people instead of putting the
effort into helping us win to put some
effort into helping to protect net
neutrality and just wanted to talk
briefly about that because you know as
we sent people to say the internet.com
my thoughts on this because a lot of
people I know that net neutrality is
relatively it's relatively controversial
right because essentially you've got two
sides of this issue
you've got the pro net
a side which is saying that Internet
service providers shouldn't be able to
discriminate in terms of the content
that's on on their infrastructure and
then you've got and which would involve
a government regulation in order to
protect that and then you've got the
point where yeah whereas they could do I
mean they would be much less limited or
unregulated to do what the heck they
wanted with their pipes but the the
other side of the coin is against net
neutrality and this is and and this is a
position that I sympathize with because
I'm generally do believe that you know
getting the government out of systems
can be helpful I'm pretty independent on
this but I do sympathise with the
position that this could be government
regulation which then would stifle
innovation so if you've got these people
that are investing all this money into
networks and infrastructure and then
you're imposing regulation on them then
you may stifle them if you treat the
Internet as a utility then it's almost
like well what happened with phones you
know phone how did phone line technology
change over the 50 years that we were
using them or whatever it's not exactly
an apples to apples comparison but I do
sympathize with the argument that this
additional regulation could stifle
innovation but here's what I'll say
regardless of whether I still feel great
about sending people to say the Internet
in to lobby their congressman and I will
I will jump in before you balance that
the reason why we said is because I mean
from our perspective I I want to protect
against a a situation where the way that
we came up like I mean this is not just
about intern attainment but if you just
that that's our experience the way we
came up was on a platform where you
could access our videos just as easy as
you could access like a bonafide
television show which a bunch of
gatekeepers funded and said okay this is
something you should watch and so it
gave us the ability
to be seen and to create to develop a
show a business to become entertainers
when otherwise before the Internet you
had to convince a small group of people
gatekeepers to allow you to make
something that would then they would put
in front of the eye
their eyeballs that they had earned and
theoretically through their network
theoretically without net neutrality the
cond the the infrastructure providers
could discriminate against content now
what I will say is that I even though
some people I saw with some comments
were like there's absolutely no evidence
of anybody ever doing that well that's
not true there are documented cases of
those principles being being infringed
upon but I do believe that competition
between service providers it's like if
somebody's like oh if Comcast comes
along and says I'm going to throttle
YouTube or Netflix well people are
probably going to go to AT&T or Verizon
because well they're not throttling
those things that so many people are
using soakin so the argument is if you
just take the hint the government's
hands out of it that the consumers will
win because there will be competition
I'm not saying I disagree with that
principle but this is what I think and
this is the whole point that I'm trying
to get to that I feel like is what makes
our country and our political system a
great thing and I also think it kind of
goes back to this whole building bridges
not walls thing that we've been trying
to talk about which is how we want to
speak into these political situations is
that I think that we're in a place in
our country right now where if you
believe if you're on one side of the
issue of us any particular issue you
demonize everybody on the other side of
the issue you believe that they have
absolutely no merit to their argument
and I actually think that there's merit
to both sides of this argument and
because of who's in power right now and
who is the chairman of the FCC we know
what those interests are so I think that
it's healthy and balancing to speak to
the consumer interest to say hey I don't
exactly know where this is going to come
down in terms of legislation but
speaking up and going to save the
Internet calm and saying that we want to
make
that consumers are protected and that P
in that content is not throttled or
discriminated against that will ensure
that whatever legislation does get
passed it increases the chances that the
consumer will and the market will both
be taken into account respectively and
we'll get the best result you see what
I'm saying so I'm saying that I feel
great about sending people to save the
internet calm and to get them to take
that action because we need a balancing
force with this particular issue right
now and hopefully what what where ever
it with it legislation lands it'll be
the best compromise because I do believe
that there's a compromise you don't want
to kill this thing with government
regulation and you don't want to say
completely hands-off and then the autumn
almighty dollar is the ultimate
motivator and then people especially
poor people usually end up suffering
more than rich people and the inequality
divide increases so all that it be said
I want to say those of you who kind of
commented on our video and we said hey
we're sending people to save the
internet and we're prone to net net
neutrality who are like you guys are
stupid so like I was like I guess this
is just a reminder I like you guys
because of your commenting not because
you're intelligent because if you're pro
net neutrality you're obviously an idiot
thanks for that thoughtful comment but I
appreciate the people who came into the
comments and gave the opposing argument
in an intelligent respectful way I
believe in that kind of dialogue but
what I'm saying is that in spite of the
fact that I that I think there are some
legitimate arguments on that side of the
table there are legitimate arguments on
this side of the table as well and we
can in this applies to so many different
issues that we are struggling with right
now is like let's not demonize a whole
group of people let's say what is the
interest what is the interest that they
have what are they scared of right now
and is there a way to address that need
in a way that we can all we can increase
the good for the most people I think
that's a mythical thing to do and I
think it applies in net neutrality but
you still should go to save the internet
calm an Lobby or or if you don't agree
you can read about it some more yeah you
know we can get you know it's we're
bringing the
attention to an issue and you can you
don't have to agree with us and we don't
expect any what we're not comfortable
asking people to who love our content to
vote for us to win something so I'm not
comfortable asking people to just do
something because I said it yes read
about is for save the Internet if you
developed an informed opinion about net
neutrality either way that you fall on
the issue
I consider that a victory because at
least you know what the issues and
what's at stake and then we can move
forward in the best possible way I think
one of the things we can agree on is
that you like listen in the air biscuits
hey and maybe something else you can
agree on is supporting the things that
support making this a possibility yes
which in one case is our own stuff you
can support us by buying the new
mythical pomade no it's new and that the
packaging is all new but it is the same
almost said award-winning I think it
might have won some awards people listen
it won Streamy show of the year last
year let me tell you we got everybody to
vote for this model love these bearded
lady products you know we pop we we
partner with bearded lady to develop the
pomade the beard oil in the lip balm and
we're gonna be doing some other stuff
soon this was still sealed people
absolutely love this this stuff is like
so high-quality they've actually they're
you know what several salons that are
just giving this out now there's awesome
there's salons that are insisting on
having it's actually good stuff good for
you but what but now yeah the packaging
is even gooder
I mean our our faces are not on it well
and this lets you know you mythical
beasts one of the things we're trying to
do with the pomade and beard oil and all
this stuff is because it's all gonna
have new packaging is that there's a lot
of people we're not just trying to
develop these things and just say hey
you know who we are and you might want
to buy this but we're trying to create a
product line that's like a legitimate
contender in that particular market and
so by calling it mythical pomade as
opposed to slapping rhett and Link on
there who are those guys this brand can
have an opportunity to develop a life of
its own and I love the love
go we've got here so the new version of
the ran ler is uh is what's happening on
and on all of our grooming mythical
products like it is look at that angular
design it'll hypnotize you if you turn
it fast enough
we also are doing a different attorney
land I looked at it upside down and he
said it looks like a weird chicken it
does it looks like a chicken like the
antlers become feet of like a big headed
cardinal but the reason we're doing this
new shape is because in testing we
determine that it is easier to access
the pomade with the wider with a wider
opening a dabble do you support
entertainment mythical dot store going
to mythical dot store you could also
pick this up on Amazon to and now on
with the biscuit last time I saw you we
were in a morgue together that's right
in a six drawer morgue it was creepy it
was so creepy and since then we and four
body systems actually I should say has
watched you in that morgue oh yeah
countless times that's even creepier
countless twelves but it was a part of
the editing process my professional job
his little encouragement clip he took it
he yeah every morning he wakes up I need
to see my mom in the morgue
encouragement clip Wow I am in the
morgue in the morning there's this we
had remember that yes we had a little
segment on some show I don't know that
we did it was called never been said
before
that's a noam chomsky thing really isn't
the linguist yeah he had a whole thing
about like you know the the unbelievable
thing about our consciousness is we can
understand that we can create sentences
that have never been said before words
that shouldn't even belong together
right we have the ability to put them
together and make them grammatically
correct you know hold on yeah
are you what is unbelievable about that
is it that we can do it or that we can
know that we're doing it I mean I think
I didn't know what you meant
I
that we can know that we're doing it and
that we can also again like form them
with proper semantics like it sounds
right like invent a totally new
linguistic thing that works right like
that's that's the hardwiring of language
right that that exists no matter what
nouns or verbs you use right like this
is how language is structured well I
think was amazing about it no Chomsky in
32nd is that what's amazing about it is
that we is that the nature of the
universe and time itself and
possibilities the fact that like we can
just sit here and one after another
create completely original things like
that's what's amazing about it to me is
that in spite of all the things that do
exist have existed and will exist we can
make novel things exist just right now
right and we are oh right now I'm about
to cry right and you've never cried
right so this is that's right in this
for you could you cry are you in are you
so many good no I'm not a cry on cue
actor Oh
a lot of young actors if they can do
that like it literally goes on your
resume yeah they need like a you know
soap opera kid but right next to tap
dancing and rollerskating what's
interesting is how kids my four kids
that's really kid actors um my father
passed away two years ago and I had to
actually do some acting work you know
like in that in that funeral no like
after he died I had to go back to work
okay you acting during the same it was I
understood thank you and what was
interesting is that I did a part that
required crying which normally I can't
do and it came like that
oh I mean like the emotion because like
the emotions were just so right there
and I realized oh this is what method
actors do right they create this
environment of emotions so that you can
like bring it like it was so it was very
it was uncomfortable though because
method actors wish that family members
died recently well they're able they can
chance exactly what I meant
they're actors are so cool people they
can access those things like I could cry
I
do cry easily but not intentionally like
commercials yeah well I can go I can
turn it on a commercial right oh yeah
like my dad's the same way and it's
funny because you know my dad and my dad
and me neither of us are known to be
sensitive emotional people because in
one sense we're not but you're hardened
in another sense it's just like all kind
of commercials maybe that would give us
more information like a yeah like a lost
dog comes back Oh something with
emotional convo yeah yeah yeah yeah but
yeah but yeah that makes sense but yeah
I'll go to if they cry and not cry I
remember feeling guilty for not crying
at my grandmother's funeral but yeah I
mean that's a different kind of but he
was consciously saving it for an acting
job that he hadn't even a quiet or for a
commercial he had yet to see someday I'm
gonna need a cute that's really need to
do well I mean who are we kidding it's
not like we have to know how to cry on
command acting buddy system I did I both
season they gave you the they gave you
the drops man I did give me the you were
trying really hard but then they just
said bring the drops in and they brought
the drops in to visit season yeah I got
the drawers this season I'm just I'm
gonna do it right now no good are you
thinking about something specific
are you just taking are you just
creating a cry face he's doing pretty
good creating a cry face no I'm not
going to it this is this is an audio
centric place we could just say come on
just sing you that I was crying yeah
link just cried like a baby
I just cried like Rhett watch the lost
dog he's got to come back oh sorry yeah
it's good dog just being lost and being
alone that's funny to you yeah right but
when the dog comes back home reunites
like one of the commercial where the guy
comes back from the soldier comes back
home oh yeah that kills me yes I'm sorry
I'm kind of Bahamut cry but guess oh I'm
not gonna
you have lost dog bumps now like goose
bumps for never mind know recently
didn't you not speak for a while
recently I did yeah I had to go on vocal
rest yeah you know what how do you know
this well because I follow her on
Instagram and I keep up with each other
oh I actually used the inherent head of
her regular basis oh but yeah I was
using on me you be some vocal rest for a
month made my bed it fed into my
hypochondria ISM he's been talking about
it we're wait why do you think you need
to go on vocal rest yeah you'll know if
you wanna join your vocal cord oh I
actually I've had him inspected twice
now I just had this like lingering sore
throat I'm doing okay but oh I'd the
only reason I thought that I might need
to go on vocal rest is because right
when I was literally the day that I was
like worrying about it the most
I saw your first video or she believes
we're peaking for you talking about this
again I was like oh no so now you have
to tell me what happened somebody was
speaking for you well I have a youtube
channel and we had literally like what's
it caught what's the handle it's Mayim
Bialik that's just spelled exactly the
way it sounds yes that was a joke or say
my name anyway so we had just really
started getting some regular you know
consistency is important just one of the
things I'm pretty sure you guys told me
when I was starting out and we had just
started like consistently putting out
videos right clocking them out and then
I went on vocal rest and we're thinking
well shoot what do we do now so what was
the trauma oh so I hemorrhaged on my
vocal cords from overuse and misuse and
polyps forming overuse behind misuse
yeah and polyps what what do you mean
what do you mean over you how did you
ever use a missus I was on a book tour
you know I burn the candle at I create a
new end of the candle to burn it at yeah
so I I'm kind of constantly producing
working writing making videos and then I
went on this book tour it involved a lot
of travel then I went to Kiev to film a
SodaStream commercial and it was very
very very long days with very few breaks
and I have a naturally raspy voice and
my dad had the same exact kind of voice
and he had the same exact diagnosis he
actually had surgery for this and I'm
hoping to avoid that so basically when
you hemorrhage on your vocal cords you
know like
they stick a camera on your throat and
the doctor looks very disappointed at
you hemorrhage twice and you but what
does that physically mean like your
blood vessels all over your cords can
hemorrhage they explode that's a that's
a word I don't like to use when I think
about my vocal cords but yeah they
explode
bloody cords like literally they're
dripping in blood bloody nodules is what
we were calling it so we had to find
creative ways to keep my youtube channel
going for how long was the bat I was bad
risk
I was on vocal rest for a month that's a
really long and I don't just mean like I
wasn't speaking publicly I was not I
mean my friend noe who works with me he
could tell you I was literally I was
angrily writing and like very frustrated
when I couldn't communicate because I'm
really I can't whisper I'm you cannot
whisper and I'm really like a person of
words like I love words you know my
parents were English teachers and like
I'm a person of like I that's my two as
my weapon is you and noam chomsky anyway
so yeah it was really crazy we did a
charades video we did videos where I
would write and have someone else read
what I wrote like try and be like poetic
about it and you were you were sitting
there silent while they read it we did
too with sign language with American
sign language interpreters actually
interesting innovative you innovate well
and also like it's actually very
humbling and empowering in a mystical I
found like spiritual way to have your
voice taken from you because it's really
the universe saying to you like like
really stop you know like listen more
and talk less have you ever done like a
silent retreat before then so I haven't
but you know as a as a Jewish person of
faith we have a lot of meditative
aspects to traditional Jewish practice
and you know Yom Kippur which is like
actually coming up in a little bit less
than two weeks you know that's a day
when we also don't eat and we don't you
know do all these other things and it's
a day where you're you're silent a lot
you know you're praying but you know so
I actually really tried to say like okay
universe I get it what what can I learn
and gather from this experience because
you know also a mentor of mine told me
to to ask the God of my understanding to
teach me lessons with joy and not with
pain
more because this is a hard way to learn
that lesson but you know they say you
keep getting the same lesson until you
learn it and so I feel like okay I
really have learned to slow down and
I've learned to listen more and speak
less and I've learned to enjoy silence
in a way that I really didn't before
I missed singing that was actually
harder than ruling
I missed my music and I would play piano
and I would like it was like it wanted
to come out but yeah pretty much
so in that given month how many slip-ups
did you have and where did you have any
moments where it's like I gotta break it
I have to speak I was because there's no
cast you know if you break a limb or
something right but they restrict it
with a cast so it heals okay there's no
cast for the vocal chords no there's
willpower I mean that's literally it I
was allowed to speak at the doctor's
office for my you know my checkups with
my ENT I was allowed to speak there but
it was almost like I didn't recognize my
own voice yeah I was so not used to
using it and I'm supposed to learn to
speak in a higher register like this but
oh yeah that's so apparently I'm resting
on my vocal cords and I've been doing
that for 41 years that's once that's one
of the reasons that you know my wife
speaks with it a higher pitch it's
because she was trained yeah as a
teenager vocally and so the first thing
I noticed when we were sort of dating is
when she needed to yell she would yell I
was like wow I actually yell and she was
like I trained myself to never yawn so I
I'm not supposed to laugh vocally this
is how my ENT said oh no laughs ready
for that like well can you just well you
guys are funny a lot say something funny
like tillich oh gosh I mean how you
spell how do you spell Mayim Bialik link
mm G ood Luc K laughs that was not
satisfying to me I knew it was a
horrible joke boy that made it feel
worse did you smell good luck yeah I
don't even understand that but it was
funny but I'm supposed to hiss I didn't
understand that but it was funny that's
the only way I am funny
so yeah and sometimes with my kids like
I I would really if I really needed to
convey something some
I was like you know I would think bang
on the table I can't speak yeah cause
it's not the kind of thing where you
undo all the work just because you speak
know it's do you want to know something
really tragic I threw my neck I threw my
back completely out halfway through
vocal rest oh and when it happened I was
alone upstairs I had just gotten out of
the shower and I was drying my hair this
has happened to me twice in my life and
when I mean my back went out the two of
you are up yeah it brought me to my
knees the pain and I could not speak or
call out so when I started doing my
friends were downstairs I started going
like this whistling yeah whistling and
Geney she's taken the hair wet because
that's right good I was drying my hair
that's out like someone come help me I
was on how long that's how you call a
dog
I was I was then I ain't with no voice I
was literally on bed rest for about ten
days oh my god I know you're back um
yeah because I also have back problems
yeah we should I mean honestly it's I
think it's tension that's being held in
my back for about 41 years yeah right
yeah so what you don't hold in your
cords you hold in your back up there I'm
finding new parts of my body the cold
pain and tension I didn't that's what
it's about you gotta release it Pilates
I don't think you're a hypochondriac
Poly's makes me burp really Pilates
makes me pass gas and I think what's it
take two classes a week once a week I'm
by myself thank you for announced pilots
yeah violates the the once a week class
where it's just me and the instructor
and it's in the morning and so I'm
always like nervous I'm like is this
gonna be a fart a farty day or not you
know and then she's folding me up and
I'm like well she's not gonna walk away
she's gonna be right here next to me for
an hour I'm so bottled up out of there
when I could as soon as I walk out of
the Pilates place it is like it's like
it's like your Nana are you like a to
the car I actually tried to do Pilates
and here's my rule nothing against 65
year old women with manicures and lots
of
Lorien makeup if you can wear all those
things for a workout that's not the
workout you need to cut you kind of come
to my class because I mean it is it's in
cities a little heavy on their 65 year
old women you know let's talk about your
book okay um I'm interested could be
drinking it drinking from that ear
biscuit jar is like drinking God nectar
from a hardened biscuit batter beverage
container available only at mythical
dots - I knew you were turning this into
an ad you sell some great things by the
way what else I just well some of your
hoodies are awesome this is not an
advertisement some of our hoodies but
I've noticed more ads on your Instagram
account that I've been seeing and the
view really cute things no we don't call
them ads we just we call them like
content adjacent yeah well anyway sorry
I'm interested in in the journey of of
you writing this book I mean he's been
out for here it is I'm holy act you took
you you talked about it so much that
your chords exploded that's right it
came out in the spring and I mean it
represents a lot of work I know yeah a
lot of yourself over over how much time
um I mean I write in infants and spurts
mm-hmm you know it was written over less
than a year okay that's good party you
already wrote got two other books right
yeah this was my third book and but
they're all totally different yeah I
wrote a book on our experience with
parenting I'm sparing my boys I wrote a
book a vegan cookbook of the recipes I
most often cook for non vegans mm-hmm
what's that called it's called my M's
beacon table now it would have been
called plant-based but back then we
didn't know to use that word oh and then
this one is going up yeah the sights of
being a girl pretty much now the
interesting thing is that okay so you
you have a you have a teenage daughter
who's
here yeah over there she's lurking but
we looming but we all have kids who are
at different stages right we've got kids
who are about to go through puberty kids
who are going through puberty and kids
who have been through puberty and can
you believe that we are responsible for
him just let's just stop for a second
and we're responsible for these people
yeah like that's scary to begin with I
think technically I am but I think
practically they know not to expect that
of me anymore yeah but like they're made
of us yeah that's I somebody that
freaked out you know just I look at them
and you know they'll do something that
reminds me of me or or of their dad and
it's like that's a human being that's
made of two people right yeah I was I
was thinking of that the other day too I
was just tripping it's like wow like you
got this the shared experience that's a
person yeah that's beautiful weird
beautiful the experience part what are
you talking about what part there was an
experiment I didn't intend for it for me
to be referring to that that's not
creating a child but what I understood
was we had this shared experience that
created a person who's like yeah that's
not that's reproduction it is yeah
do you write it do you write about that
in here oh yes oh yeah that's in there
get what is the word that you would use
technical very clear very clearly stated
well and I really tried to write I mean
I'm trained as a neuroscientist so you
know I I'm a science communicator you
know I've always taught science and
that's what I did for many years after
getting my PhD so I really wanted to
present it in an age-appropriate way but
also not a talking down to kids way
right because I think that you know a
lot of us were kind of spoken to that
way and or not more not smoked we're not
spoken to at all and I really wanted to
present it and like here's the thing
like let's not be afraid of these words
you don't have to love them you know
have to shout them from the rooftops but
these are the parts of your body this is
what happens and you know it's I'm
pretty conservative you know I don't I
don't do a lot of things that I think
there's pressure to do in a lot of teen
books because I really wanted it to
appeal not only to younger kids but to
kids who are late bloomers like I was
what do you so what do you mean pressure
to do in a teen book like talking like
preachy stuff
well like preachy stuff or kind of
moralistic stuff and getting into some
of the more complicated aspects that
certain teenagers encounter when they're
dating and you know I didn't feel like
it needed to be like a normalized yeah I
didn't want to normalize I mean I didn't
want I didn't want to pass judgment on
behaviors but I also you know didn't
want to have to feel like we need to
talk about the full gamut of things
which in my opinion are best left to be
discussed privately or with your
intimate partner got it I understand
does that make sense
yeah and I'll explain it - link yeah
you've been respectful because my
daughter's here - maybe we don't want to
talk about that stuff
I did ask Lily - yeah because that's the
thing - come on here yeah cuz you don't
the good news is is because she wrote
this book you don't have to talk to Lily
right right it's like I don't have a
daughter I mean I've had some awkward
talks with my boys already still
figuring that oh yeah but I don't have
to worry about this I don't have to have
this conversation that that you have but
you know you probably should also talk
to her in addition to just give me a
room well this might honestly I think
that for a lot of dads and also moms
it's also a good kind of framework and
guideline for a set of conversations
because I do leave a lot you know kind
of open-ended like these are some things
that you can talk about with a trusted
you know adult - but even you know basic
things about Anatomy like you know guys
especially of our generation weren't
really taught a lot and when you have a
daughter especially if you're a you know
an engaged dad the way dad's now are
encouraged to be and are yeah you want
to know more about you know your
daughter and how she can't no kind of
functions I mean my dad literally said
well your mother said she was gonna talk
to you about the birds and bees she
never did no dad she never did like my
dad might have this conversation when I
was in my 30s I didn't no one ever
talked to me he's like your mother was
supposed to do ha ha ha she said she was
Mel take care of it you know right so I
mean what's the sweet spot of the target
audience for this thing I'll read the
Aretha 10 to 18 in it and it
my eleven-year-old read it my boy and he
said the language was fine you know he
didn't like seeing certain diagrams but
normal okay
chapter one how our bodies work to how
we grow three how we learn for how we
love five how we cope and six how we
matter now
I know that I wanted to bring Lily on
because she's read your book right and
I'm super liked it otherwise this is
gonna be a very awkward yeah let's see
Lily come on - come on - the round table
of dim lighting here and Lily
throw your yeah put those on yeah and
you can hear yourself and bring the mic
you know cozy up to that mic the first
rhett or link progeny - to be on your
yeah you set the record we've I've
talked I've probably talked about Lily
more than any other time especially
going through the back surgery and
everything we talked about it more on
your biscuits than anywhere else and
super proud of look at her she's doing
it she's done yeah okay she's sitting up
she's got the best posture now Lily I I
made you read this book in preparation
for coming on here right well no I my
mom well she she told me she was like oh
mine's writing a book I was like oh I'm
really excited to read it and I read it
in like the first three weeks like maybe
like two weeks after it came out I got
it and then I read it and I got a sneak
sneak copy yeah did I not give it to you
like you did know that's what yeah
that's the one you gave to her okay yeah
okay I get I didn't make you buy your
own lose your allowance like I made my
kids you gotta get on yeah yeah but I
read it in like I was kind of off and on
cuz I was like deciding between like
three books if I was gonna read them all
at the same time or if I was gonna read
them in separate I don't know sections
of the month but I really I really did
enjoy
Wow no awkward conversations okay well
I'm sure we can find so yeah we'll make
it awkward don't worry you know I'm
gonna make it all right yeah I don't
know how but I'm sure I will
but um how does your body work Lily
[Applause]
she's used to it but one like for the
overall theme I really loved how you use
your knowledge of the brain and of well
being a girl yourself but also like
using personal experiences in more non
scientific situations to like explain
different things and make it and feel
more real like not not just oh this is a
fact book this is like telling you
what's gonna happen what what you're
made of and like what that's gonna do
like you it's not a science book yes I
really enjoy because I love science I
heard you liked biology yes I do if
there's some neurology going on in this
thing in the book yeah yeah I mean I
talked about some of the chemicals that
are you know activated particularly in
the love chapter I talked about sort of
the the neuro chemistry of that talked
about fear and anxiety and depression I
talked about some of the chemicals for
that I mean you know the brain controls
everything you do and perceive so you
know kind of everything is neuroscience
is you know sort of well I'm a little
partial but but yeah there's their
specific brain conversations in it but
you're saying there's also like some
juicy maíam stories in there oh yeah I
talk about my experience you know liking
boys and things like that and how poorly
that went oh is this the kind of book
that you need to like take like a
satchel full of them to school and just
start handing them out other other girls
you think that would be how would that
go I I mean I've definitely talked to
some of my friends about hey I read this
book and it's like really great and you
should you should totally read it
like make them buy their own copy that
we need yeah well I know I don't trust
people borrowing my books it's been it's
real gone badly you got a right you got
a what do they do with you write your
name them or they make those in the old
days it was like a little imprint that
you'd put on it oh no no I'm talking
like a wax no no but it's like um it it
makes an imprint it lifts the paper up
in some places like your initials yeah
oh I know what that's called I got one
for my bar mitzva it's like a thing and
you mark every major there every book
boss it's an emboss er not every page
every page of every book you've ever
read you've emboss'd this is how we know
you're boiling but you wrote it because
you thought that it you you filled the
white space so to speak I didn't have
the right this book didn't exist when I
was actually there were books that were
about science you know and about like
how your body works but they weren't you
know presented like this and we have you
know there's like it's a comic book
artists style you know illustrations and
showing I also wanted to show different
shapes and sizes and body types and and
talk about that so yeah cuz I mean it
definitely didn't exist when I was a kid
and I needed that kind of you know
information and also I think a lot of
what I talk about is the variety of
experience that but people but
especially girls have that you know I
didn't know when it's normal to start
your menstrual cycle like I didn't know
what's normal
I didn't know what's abnormal I didn't
know that it's normal to be abnormal you
know that your body takes some time to
settle into what its gonna be like and
you know that what you look like you
know I was a head shorter than every kid
till about 7:30 or ninth grade and now
I'm an average height for a woman you
know in my whole life I thought oh my
gosh no one's gonna like me I don't have
breasts really short my nose is too big
like that was my experience and what I
wanted to I'm on TV I'm very famous that
actually that hadn't helped I mean that
and I talk about that also like you know
most of the the young women reading this
book were not alive when the snow was on
and probably haven't seen it she was on
a show called blossom when I was young
you know have you seen that you haven't
I have seen it but where could you where
can you back what where can you binge
watch blossom now flicks no no it's not
know and it's only the only the first
two seasons were released by shout
factory they didn't release seasons
three four and five they're in like a
vault so we write the first two seasons
oh my people have posted them illegally
I don't know I mean doesn't feel that
illegal but it is but anyway I do talk
about that how sometimes getting too
much attention can also feel yucky like
there are different kinds of people
there are introverts they're extrovert
but how did you because that's a
question I have is I can't imagine us
having you know the fact that by the
time this all started clicking into
place for us as a career
we were already you know 30 years old
with kids and had you know had had real
jobs and but there's just so many kids
now who they get that you know
especially on YouTube it's like
something catches and all of a sudden
you've got it's a 17 year old kid who is
famous I mean I I can't imagine what
would have happened to me how did you
turn out normal well I don't know that I
turned out normal I mean uh you know how
did you turn out healthy I'm an odd bird
as they go um you know I I don't I don't
know how old were you I was so when I
was on blossom I was 14 to 19 and I was
in a movie called beaches when I was 12
right it was like the young Bette Midler
so I really just started acting a bit
before beaches you know I um I I know I
grew up with many people in the industry
some of whom have passed away you know
from
excesses you know and so I don't like to
say like well here's how they should
have you know lived so that that
wouldn't have happened to them because
mental illness and drug abuse and
alcohol abuse like those things happen
whether you're on TV or not you know to
too many people so I know that what
worked for me you know I I mean I come
from an immigrant background my
grandparents are immigrants so I was
raised with a very strong work ethic
very kind of disciplined and
conservative you know household I had
chores and you know I I had a whole
structured life and my parents were very
strict and I think for my personality
you know that created boundaries that
felt good
for me I was a very anxious child you
know I was not very social also the
world was very different then there was
no internet there was no publicity
telling girls that they should wear
extensions and have their lips done when
they're 16 you know like I looked like a
kid when I was a kid and you know a lot
of of the public females that we see now
I think don't have that that that right
to sort of be innocent public people's
so I think you know for me that was
really instilled by my parents but again
you know I knew kids in high school who
weren't on TV who were also getting into
trouble and there are a lot of reasons
for that
right sorry I just made it sad well you
know you mean you talked about how you
were an anxious child that I I that I
mean I'm an anxious adult - I didn't
mean to say it like you know you figure
out of it well that resonates with me I
mean you know raising my kids I'm not
that well I'm reminded like now when
they're going into school and like
there's a big milestone okay moving from
like home school in charter school
they're moving in a public school and
for the first time this year and
encounter a lot of new things and
anxiety that comes along with that and
I'm reminded of like Lando going in his
second grade
it's kind of like when I went to
kindergarten right and even preschool I
remember being so anxious yeah you know
I think um it wasn't something that I
was aware of that I was actively taught
how to understand what was going on my
brain and in my in my body just to use
that as kind of a case study anxiety for
me was something that it was it was
college when I really started to
identify well the way I interact with
with school is totally based on anxiety
like until within iasts I go from
assignment to assignment trying to do
trying to get enough of it done ahead of
time so that I cannot be wigging out
that it's not done like I was an anti
procrastinator because I was I was an
anxious wreck right but I can I can
trace it back through childhood but it
was something that I never actively
talked about
I think people didn't you know yeah like
culture is different now and I wanted
also I wanted this book to be culturally
relevant you know we didn't know what
what even gender fluidity was much less
you know but even it yeah even if it's
not your thing to be a gender fluid
person like this is the vernacular that
our kids are growing up with you know so
I at least wanted to introduce terms so
that like we know what we're talking
about you know and then people can have
whatever opinions they want you know but
I think that's part of it when we were
right like no one wanted to hear that I
was anxious they wanted like like finish
what's on your plate go do your homework
and I'll tuck you in and don't tell my
dad when he gets home from work cuz he's
in a bad mood
those were the rules like go outside and
play that may still be a real sometimes
you know when not today it's not a rule
she doesn't know this and understand it
but no one cared what we wanted for
dinner
like with my kids it's like what would
you like oh oh I don't want that I don't
care I was talking to Jesse about this
so today I was like we have so many
interactions with our children why do i
and I've only got two I was like why do
we have so many interactions about
everything and I was like I'm just
thinking back to like the way I
interacted with my phone and it was just
like you're outside yeah and then your
mom yells to come back yeah then you eat
these don't eat you get in trouble
that's me and then you go watch
something and then it's Bette I was like
just getting Shepard to go to bed oh my
gosh it's like you know what it was for
me it was Dukes of Hazzard going off and
I specifically remember the NBC sound
yes and that was like didn't you really
fell asleep you're like Pavlov and so I
was like oh I'm gonna go to sleep it's
like boy I wish I could have a bell that
would make my kids go to say no it's
like no we have to have an argument and
we have conversation oh yeah yeah but
ultimately I put the thing I keep
reminding myself of us like I think that
I think this is better I think this is a
better way but it is more exhausting
more taxing for the parents more
exhausting yeah yeah
but your cultivate I mean isn't your
cultivating self-awareness like I mean
if it's
i I Lily I'm curious for you you know is
there something that it impacted how you
thought about yourself like the level
that you think about yourself and how
your brain works or okay you know for me
it was anxiety that I didn't think about
you know is there something like that
from the from the book for you that got
you thinking yeah I mean it's really
just like I guess the sciency stuff so
like I'll read something or even in
biology class right now I'll be like oh
we're learning about DNA or oh this is
what happens in your brain when you do
this and then it's like oh my gosh that
actually happens in my head like there's
there's a there's a thing in my head
that does that stuff and then it's like
oh I like right here in my arm there's
there's DNA like there's a cell that has
DNA in the nucleus and it's like that's
that's that's just like sometimes it's
just like whoa and some whoa and
sometimes as impulses in your brain that
you know you can separate yourself from
that you don't have to act on it you are
not your brain that you're saying yeah
you brain is just an organ that just it
has all these impulses you are not your
thoughts do you mean wait hold on you
don't have to act on everything
electrical impulses or like urges yeah
I'm talking about like dating urges well
that's just a date as a nerd hell I
don't know I don't mean I don't want to
put Lily on the spot but I actually
speak about the part of the brain that
is not fully developed in teenagers
which is responsible for controlling
urges and it's the reason that we don't
like young people I mean one of the
reasons we don't like young people to
drink alcohol to do drugs even to be
responsible for driving or being
responsible for four other important
things is because the frontal lobe of
your brain is not fully developed and
that literally is what controls impulses
and that notion of like if your parents
tell you don't do this
and you know you remember being a
teenager it's like why not that's
literally like yes don't you're not done
developing do you think a neuroscientist
told the rental car companies that the
magic age was 2045 right because it's so
weird that once you get past 25 that's
when you can rent a car technically and
the rates go down and that's when you're
well my cortex is completely my money my
kids asked me the other day we were
talking about what they were learning
about banking like we were learning
about the fact that they have account
and well when can I have that account
mama and I said well when you're 25 and
they said well why not 18 I said because
your father and I sat with a lawyer and
we decided that we didn't want you
having money at your disposal at 18
because the things that you think of at
18 are not necessarily the things you
might want to do with money yeah why I
remind myself without a lot of times
when I'm reasoning I'm gonna use the
term reasoning with my chaos and in like
luck you know who's a teenager now and
then I find myself talking them about
something and then I have to remember
I'm like I want to just take the logical
thought that I feel like I'm having and
just put it in his brain yeah but they
also have to experience things for
themselves right which is important but
but not dating no and you know it's
funny because someone was saying oh you
gotta learn it for yourself I said no I
was a very obedient child and teenager
and I didn't do the things that they
said not to do and it turned out okay I
figured it out right I my best friend
she was like she told me before I read
your book she is like okay so this like
the frontal lobe isn't fully developed
when like until 25 for males and I don't
for females is it sooner that it's
probably yeah and I wouldn't be
surprised and then and then win it and
then it's more developed in comparison
yeah yeah so thinking of the teenage
years for girls and guys but like is
there's this moment of realization like
that makes a lot of sense right but also
like when you know you you don't wake up
at your age and say like well here's
another
with me not having all my faculties you
know you feel like you've got it
together you know yeah you're going to
your life and all of all the things that
that my kids and that our kids and that
you know young people experience it's
it's real you know there may not be all
the information and experience but it's
real and I remember the pain of not
being allowed to watch this movie or not
being able to watch this TV show cuz my
parents were really strict about that or
not being able to go out at night and it
felt really unfair I was the only you
know teenager who wasn't allowed to
drive when the first girl in our class
got her driver's license and every other
kid got to go out driving with her and
they had a great time and I had to stay
home because my parents didn't think
that that was safe you know and I
remember that just feels crummy like
even though logically I get it
it feels crummy to be that kid you know
oh yeah anyway I hear that quite a bit
well Lilly we can let you off the hook
here and is that do you have any other
pressing questions for my um based on
the book I'm really putting you on the
spot you're doing great by the way she
almost seems prepped but I know she's
not because that would have required
some forethought from me from you this
is your opportunity to take up for me
and say how I'm such a great dad
it's no longer about my I'm or her but
I'm gonna be to wit your party words
that's something to do with how great I
am because you know you're my favorite I
mean I tell you that all the time when
none of the other kids are around sure
not that like our dog is your favorite
child or whatever oh no none of that
did it have I said that out loud but I
still love you a lot I mean I do love
you all right listen to this act yeah if
I ever have to cry on cue my think of
that moment
Lilly thank you so you can you can sit
back oh you know you don't have to be on
the be on the in the in the pressure
seat anymore the hot seat I think it's
what it's called so there you go 17th
century well thanks for thanks for
having me on
for being on yeah thanks for reading my
book I'm liking it maybe one day you'll
write a book you write a book like this
but being a vegan I won't let her be a
vegan draw the line there you know we
actually just we just right before we
came in here I was like this happened to
me like eight hours ago I saw our
printed book for the first time I can't
what you just saw your arse like even in
the Edit all day yeah I know I I saw an
hour ago I saw it on I was talking to
Rhett and I looked down at the desk and
I saw we've had like preliminary
paperback version right book can't leave
copies the galley copy yeah and I
thought that's what it wasn't in it was
shiny a little bit different so uh I saw
it I can't wait
I wasn't gonna bring that up because I
want this was about her no I'm just
saying I'm just looking at her book and
thinking the fact that like it's like
it's such a good feeling right well my
aunt my aunt just sent me a picture from
a book store in San Jose and it was like
my book was on the shelf and she just
couldn't believe it you know she took a
picture and yeah cuz there's I don't
know what it is you know I mean as
somebody who's you know you know you've
been in a lot of things you've created a
lot of things and like you know all the
videos that we've created that are still
out there but it just I don't know
there's it's not as permanent yeah it's
like ya got this book and it's just like
I was actually thinking about it in the
context of the kids I mean we talked
about this as we were writing it was
like so much of this because a lot of it
is very memoir based and I was like
there's so much of this stuff that I've
told bits and pieces of these stories to
the boys but it's like oh it's like yeah
I just read this book because yeah yeah
absolutely was a point when we were
right in and I was like this is gonna be
even if only our kids read this that
would be so glad and me yeah I don't
know he's just looking at looking at the
physical book and Union is your third
one
it feels very like Forrest Gump to me
you know like I put my face on this book
that's not really much you know like I
feel like I've been inserted in yeah and
also I don't remember Forrest Gump being
like it knows right now like well no not
like that
face up book go straight just the way he
had the moment
you know but it well and also the I was
a kid once see that yeah the in the back
of young my am with a pickle and you
know how it is like when celebrities
write books right and you actually you
said this I don't like that like and I
and for good reason right because people
it's so many people and I think this is
definitely true it's not any less true
of youtubers it's just like oh you got
an audience
far too booked out yeah so they'll buy
it and we you know and that that trend
started happening on YouTube yeah they
call it amateur by amateur autobiography
right right yeah and the nice
condescending it oh no I I didn't call
it that that's the thing that well it's
not someone who's an author it's someone
you know who hasn't written before and
they're writing their story for the you
know the fan base that will find it you
know something that they want to read
well then you're thinking like okay what
just you know fine did they actually
write it not everybody did right right
so it's probably some ghostwriter here
and some of them you pick up and you're
like this is not a book this is this is
pictures well sometimes it's like
stories you know so anyway but the thing
I well I'm bragging about your book and
our book together that's what this um
this is turning into it we're trying to
make some sort of association here no
because I got some coattails the
connection happening because I can feel
the like with all the stuff that you've
done but especially with this one this
seems like the one that is the most like
this is the thing that I had to get out
oh yeah and also I think what's special
and I'm assuming you know you may have
had a similar experience like many many
people have come to me in the past years
since I've been on Big Bang Theory to
say can we slap your face on a book and
call it science for girls and sell a lot
of copies and I kept saying no because I
mean that's not it's not true to it
forget about my brand like what science
you know and I literally I literally
sent an email to one of these publishers
saying I'm sorry which science do you
mean human biology do you mean physics
doing chemistry like seems like what do
you mean there's no scent like just saw
us right it's like that's not that's not
about to slap my face on and this was
really you know when Jill Santa Polo
from penguin reached out to me she
read an article that I wrote for gratin
nation for my website about the episode
where Amy and Sheldon are intimate for
the first time and I wrote about it as a
late bloomer playing a late bloomer on
television and she literally reached out
for that reason and that really spoke to
me because she said I liked the way you
spoke about being a late bloomer and
some of the benefits of that and I'm
wondering if you'd like to share that
with a broader audience and I said well
since you seem to be a real person of
substance can I pitch you this and I
pitched this book I said what if that's
just part of the experience of sharing
about what it's like to be female some
of us are late bloomers some of us
aren't here are the things you should
know about your body that no one ever
told me you know here's the way to kind
of put yourself out into the world as a
female so it's it's the book that you
know I feel most closely connected to
because I really had to fight for it
yeah right it wasn't just like let's do
a book and you know I mean you know as
lily indicated like there's science and
like I'm trained as a scientist that's
what I that's what I am it's not cutesy
stories about like first I like this boy
you know it's like I like this boy that
no one else like because he was a goth
and I cried about him his name was Misha
Misha is mentioned in the book yes gosh
he was yeah he was dark and he liked Sex
Pistols and is he still a goth you look
him up no he says that I've spoken to
him since we like connected in college
and he said that the years that I had a
crush on him which was literally from
like seventh grade through 12th grade he
said those were his golden years baby
it's been all down
I never dress in black he's not he's not
goth anymore um I don't think so it's
really tough to maintain that pretty
ironic isn't it yeah he was not to be
your golden no he was more like he was
like black Andy he was more punk rock
I'd say okay you know there was well
there was a you know it like especially
a night rule north carolina's like it
was an eyeliner involved we just called
no no no eyeliner now the alternative
kids yes they were they yeah well I like
yeah well Punk goth what is that they've
rushed us all together there's a
category of people called hairs that
very few people seem to know that term I
don't know it's a West Coast term really
for sure
no the guys who are like the Metallica
shirts and the skinny black like they
kind of look like Ramones guys okay we
called them hash fry we just didn't have
any
and you weren't a hash or you just know
Christ oh no I wore I wore Doc Martens
and fishnets almost every day
and I was like the girl who wore like
the peasant skirts and like the Lennon
glasses and you know okay
ironic I get it I read Dostoyevsky in my
spare time oh wow yeah I didn't read
until I was 30 I wrote a book Yeah right
look at you now ya know I read some
about the book yeah yeah but substance
the word that you use when you when you
were talking about the editor bro shoot
yeah a person of substance because you
had an idea ideas of substance and
wanted to write a book of substance and
I just it's not I don't know it's it's I
don't want to be one that's because like
it's becoming more rare it's not it is
though and people say you know and also
I mean you know the YouTube world like I
think it's really impossible to try and
do what I've done already which is like
I'm not I don't think I'm not
interesting I just like have a lot of
strong opinions about things but people
seem to want to hear them and we're
trying to lighten me up a little bit I
mean I've been told I'm too old since
I'm five years old yeah I've been told
I'm too cerebral and too you know and I
can be fun hey listen you've seen me be
fine I've seen you forcing something
with Waccamaw yeah okay am I allowed to
look at my hand no but yeah but you know
I like things of substance because for
me those have been the things that have
caused the most personal change and the
most change that I see that I can affect
in the world like that's literally like
that's a thing of mine right for reals
yet hope yeah it's like dent the
universe right logan paul says yeah
let's talk about substance hey come on I
mean if you're choosing between Logan
and Paul I mean I mean Logan and Jake if
you choose between a first and a last
name of the same person you're choosing
your kind of just talking about it first
I mean you're choosing between Logan and
Jake I mean I think the substances on
Logan side that's all I gotta say in the
Logan Jake debate Wow there you go
what do you think about that I'm wearing
a Wolverine shirt so Logan okay
[Laughter]
so your your oldest son read the book
correct and then as I said first editor
yeah and these like right one for me too
did he whisper because of nose but so
did boy boying up with you on the cover
forrest gump on the cover boying up i
wonder how much it would you you would
you're not have to pay tom oh how much
would you have to pay Tom Hanks to just
be on the cover of a book you're like
that's all you have to do I say it's by
you it's just I want you to be on the
cover of money I don't know the answer
to that we should have thought of that
we should have put Tom Hanks in this so
we we we could list that as a sentence
that's never been uttered how much would
it take to put Tom Hanks on the cover of
a book yeah how much money I'm pretty
sure that I'll probably have a lot of
frustrated editors all the ones that
called you just then called him and said
that he probably gets phone calls by
that kind of thing all that time mm-hmm
well even though it's been out for a few
months I'm glad we were able to talk
about I really appreciate it I
appreciate your support
yeah I know if you don't have it get it
it is still out it's a it's a fun read I
mean it's it's a light read it's not
like a text book did you do inaudible
and inaudi I did just before my voice
went out oh you did I did it was the
first book I've ever narrated of the
three that I've done I've never you know
spoken the other ones and it was really
fun mm-hmm a little hard to explain some
of the diagrams yeah right sorry cuz
yeah because we've recorded our book of
a few weeks ago and yeah you have to
kind of work around but but the thing
that we talked about is it's a totally
unique experience because totally it's
like well for the listener you mean yeah
we actually end up having to explain
things in a way that you wouldn't get
and you don't got the book so you kind
of gotta do both you don't also like I
found the experience kind of interesting
you don't think that much about how you
speak but when you read things for a
long period of time you start having the
same intonation every sentence
representin sounds like this so she
would stop me and say like you're
getting a little singsong and like she
got a little Stern about it yeah rising
sorry
well we sat here I mean there's to it
well there's what we would
we would bat it back and forth so you'd
have we'd have some built-in recovery
time right but yeah the director guy he
would sit right here right and then we
would usually correct each other before
he would he was like why are you playing
why am I even here they dress thank you
jumping down each other's throats I got
to back away slowly it's getting heated
and awkward in here and they're doing my
job a your next book he awkward right
right that now Fujiyama Hank's on the
cover I get to be heated okay
sure you can be first this time well
they do you I don't want to be awkward
I'll be hoping that long enough he did
it awkward storing time hold on that's
gonna come on after Big Bang Theory yeah
it's just like no one tapes unis heated
and awkward it'll be on for a few
episodes sound like sorry two guys John
heated and Michael Mike awkward we can
sell it it's sold will you be we be in
it why is it John heated in my car we
sell this show you're my new you win
okay alright I wanted to make it like a
development deal right here right here
if we sell John heated and Mike awkward
you've had some really face they get
they get in a dating yeah they get in it
like they get in a love quadrant with
hot and heavy allocated in hoc awkward
getting the love quadrants I with hot
and has about what's a love quadrant I
think it's like polyamory no Oh for Pete
no but rappers away you can't put
rhombus on network television I'm just
saying it's like a love triangle but
it's videos about this issue of
polyamory really cuz I know nothing
about it and I got it all wrong in my
first video so I made an apology video
ok did you take but so you didn't take
the first one down no I spoke to four
people actually clinicians in the poly
am community who told me what I
literally gotten not just like oh you're
wrong you should think what you got
wrong like
I use the wrong words and so I I made a
new video and it's kind of crazy but I
got some really great love people saying
like good that you left the other one up
is all about saying yeah so you can keep
monetizing so we're like thank you for
admitting you were wrong and even if
it's still not your jam
we appreciate you clarifying the
terminology well we can need to consult
them I might need to send you those
links yeah cuz maybe you didn't mean
Paul II am maybe you meant open
relationship well I I was just I was
just never mind
I was making an offhanded joke about a
love triangle has nothing to do with any
of this guys but you said love right I
said I love Quadra because it's 440 but
it's the same it's a lot more than hot
and heavy
yeah all I'm saying is that each person
like the next person like the next
person there's no overlap train of like
oh yeah train it's a train man is it a
dance a show it's a Soul Train it's a
dance it's a it's a it's a reality Soul
Train bag we're calling it heated and
awkward maíam thanks Bertha
thanks for coming in we'll have you
sound the sound sign the table oh this
is fun yeah it's a super fun once again
I would love to and we need to talk
about our medical issues yeah we do I'm
gonna I'm gonna check out for that
[Music]